Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour et
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de "Parlement hebdo", l'émission
qui vous fait revivre les temps
forts à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat sous le regard d'un
invité.
- Alexandre Poussart: Et on
accueille Roger Karoutchi.
Bonjour.
- Roger Karoutchi: Bonjour.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous êtes
sénateur LR des Hauts-de-Seine.
- Kathia Gilder: On parlera de la
marche contre l'antisémitisme, ce
dimanche.
L'initiative n'en finit plus de
diviser.
Les présidents de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat défileront.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les
sénateurs ont examiné le projet de
loi immigration.
La majorité de droite du centre du
Sénat a durci le texte, notamment
sur les conditions de
régularisation des travailleurs
sans papiers dans les métiers en
tension.
Le Sénat a supprimé toutes les
protections existantes pour les
étrangers face aux obligations de
quitter le territoire français.
- Kathia Gilder: Ils défileront ce
dimanche contre l'antisémitisme.
Voulue par Yaël Braun-Pivet et
Gérard Larcher, la marche
républicaine a pour but de
rassembler, mais face au boycott
de LFI et à la participation du
RN, l'union nationale semble
introuvable.
- Un rassemblement pour la
République contre l'antisémitisme,
c'est le mot d'ordre de la
manifestation initiée
conjointement par la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale et le
président du Sénat.
- Nous incarnons deux
institutions.
Elles sont la démocratie
parlementaire, et ça a vraiment du
sens.
- Dès mardi, RN annonce sa
participation, provoquant un
certain malaise dans le camp
présidentiel.
- Nous parlons aux Français.
C'est une marche civique que nous
faisons, ce n'est pas un
rassemblement politique.
Ce n'est pas un meeting.
Nous n'avons invité aucun parti
politique.
- Si Jordan Bardella, président du
RN, si Marine Le Pen s'invitent,
seront-ils les bienvenus?
- Il n'est pas question de savoir
s'ils seront les bienvenus.
Ce qui est certain, c'est que le
président du Sénat et moi-même,
nous défilerons en tête de ce
cortège et nous ne défilerons pas
côté du Rassemblement National.
- La présence du RN n'est pas un
problème, pour le président LR.
- Est-ce que si ce n'était pas un
parti républicain, vous pensez
qu'Emmanuel Macron les aurait
invités?
- Hors de question, pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon, de défiler.
Ce n'est pas ça la position de ses
alliés de la NUPES.
Ecologistes, communistes et
Socialistes appellent à manifester
dans le calme.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
serez à cette marche?
Est-ce que l'appel a été largement
entendu par les parlementaires?
- Roger Karoutchi: Bien sûr, j'y
serai.
Je serai présent, comme beaucoup
de sénateurs LR, centristes ou
socialistes.
Le Sénat sera massivement
représenté dans cette
manifestation.
Nous n'avons pas d'état d'âme.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cette
marche, c'est suffisant pour
gagner le combat contre
l'antisémitisme en France?
- Roger Karoutchi: Bien sûr que
non.
C'est de la symbolique.
Nous sommes aujourd'hui 5 semaines
après ce funeste 7 octobre.
Nous sommes à 500 actes
antisémites.
Il faut des mesures fortes de la
part de la police, de la justice.
La manifestation en elle-même
n'empêche pas des actes
antisémites, mais c'est une
symbolique de dire que nous
n'acceptons pas les dérives.
Nous ne banalisons pas les
dérives.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que le RN
a toute sa place dans cette marche
républicaine?
- Roger Karoutchi: C'est un appel
à une marche de l'ensemble de la
population française pour dire
"non" à l'augmentation des actes
antisémites.
Quand vous dites qu'on appelle
toute la population française,
vous allez mettre de côté les 25%
qui votent RN?
C'est grotesque!
Ce n'est pas parce qu'ils
manifestent qu'on va voter pour
Marine Le Pen à la prochaine
présidentielle.
Je trouve tout à fait légitime que
les citoyens français qui se
reconnaissent dans le
Rassemblement National, et ils
sont nombreux, trop, par rapport à
nous...
- Kathia Gilder: C'est un parti
républicain, pour vous, le RN?
- Roger Karoutchi: Pardon, mais je
ne dis pas que pour participer à
cette manifestation, il faut avoir
son brevet civique.
C'est une marche contre la
résurgence inadmissible et
l'accroissement inadmissible des
actes antisémites.
Tout le monde y est convié.
J'aurais bien aimé que pour une
fois, Mélenchon ou Le Pen se
disent: "On y va."
On essaie de dire que l'unité de
la nation se fait sur le fait que
nous n'acceptons pas la résurgence
des actes antisémites.
Je regrette profondément la
position de LFI.
Je regrette sincèrement la
position d'une instance pour qui
j'ai beaucoup d'estime et de
considération: le Conseil français
du culte musulman.
Je trouve que franchement, pour
une fois, les manifestations non
politiques, non partisane, qui
peuvent rassembler du monde, c'est
dommage d'avoir des polémiques.
- Alexandre Poussart: Jordan
Bardella estime qu'il ne croyait
pas que Jean-Marie Le Pen était
antisémite.
Pourtant, il a été condamné.
- Roger Karoutchi: Que Jordan
Bardella ait commis une faute
lourde en disant cela...
J'ai vu qu'il s'était rétracté
dans les 48 heures.
Je ne dis pas que je vais juger...
Si monsieur Mélenchon était venu à
la manif, j'aurais dit que c'était
normal.
- Kathia Gilder: Malgré son tweet
au vitriol?
- Roger Karoutchi: C'est
parfaitement choquant, mais bon,
de toute façon, ils ne viennent
pas, ils ne viennent pas.
Monsieur Mélenchon, depuis
maintenant un certain temps, est
sorti de l'arc républicain
classique.
Les propos tenus par lui ou par
certains de ses soutiens,
d'ailleurs...
Pas tous.
Il y a des députés LFI qui ont un
comportement tout à fait
républicain, comme François Ruffin
ou Raquel Garrido.
- Kathia Gilder: Qui a été exclue,
d'ailleurs.
- Roger Karoutchi: Quand on tient
des propos cohérents, on est
exclus.
Ce n'est pas rassurant.
Franchement, personne n'imagine
que je puisse voter un jour pour
LFI, mais je pense qu'il y a des
électeurs LFI qui votent LFI par
conviction que la société doive
être chamboulée.
Ca n'a rien à voir avec
l'antisémitisme.
On peut se dire que la société
doit être chamboulée et à la fois
être très hostile aux actes
antisémites.
J'aurais compris que, quel que
soit le côté partisan des
dirigeants, beaucoup de citoyens
ou d'adhérents, et j'espère que
beaucoup seront à la
manifestation, diront que pour
eux, les actes antisémites, c'est
non.
Il faut arrêter de vouloir, y
compris dans des marches de ce
genre, dire: "Pas untel ou untel."
Cette société française est déjà
si fragmentée que si, sur des
sujets comme ça, on continue les
anathèmes, on n'y arrivera jamais.
- Kathia Gilder: Une dernière
question sur les appels aux
cessez-le-feu qui se multiplient.
Vous défendez le droit d'Israël à
se défendre?
Vous dites quoi sur ces appels aux
cessez-le-feu?
- Roger Karoutchi: L'un n'empêche
pas l'autre.
Je suis président du groupe France
Israël au Sénat.
J'ai vu, comme d'autres, des
images du 7 octobre.
Quand vous avez vu ces images,
vous ne vous dites pas qu'on peut
traiter le Hamas comme un Etat.
Je ne sais pas ce que ça veut
dire, un cessez-le-feu, tant que
les otages ne sont pas libérés.
Si les otages sont libérés,
c'est...
On insiste sur des couloirs
humanitaires.
Toute vie est une vie.
Toute vie est une vie, que ce soit
à Gaza ou en Israël.
Toute population civile atteinte,
c'est un peu...
C'est extrêmement agressif par
rapport à la nature humaine.
En même temps, comment négocier un
cessez-le-feu tant que les otages
ne sont pas libérés?
D'ailleurs, je rappelle que la
position française initiale, il y
a 4 semaines, c'était de dire:
"Libération des otages, puis
cessez-le-feu."
Or, les otages ne sont pas
libérés.
Tout le monde a l'air de négocier:
le Qatar, la Turquie...
Qu'ils obtiennent d'abord les
otages.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
du projet de loi immigration.
Le Sénat a examiné cette semaine
ce texte.
La majorité de droite et du centre
l'a considérablement durci.
Un texte qui est porté par Gérald
Darmanin.
Les sénateurs ont durci le
dispositif qui prévoit des
conditions de régularisation des
travailleurs sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension.
- Pour: 191.
Contre: 138.
Le Sénat a adopté l'amendement de
suppression.
- Exit l'article 3, place à
l'article 4 bis.
C'est le fruit de l'accord trouvé
entre la droite et le centre au
Sénat.
Il durcit les conditions de
régularisation des sans-papiers.
- Nos collègues LR ont voulu
muscler le texte, sur la ligne qui
est la leur.
L'essentiel, c'était qu'un texte
sorte du Sénat.
- Le compromis prévoit que les
régularisations au cas par cas
restent à la main du préfet,
alors que le gouvernement voulait
une régularisation
de plein droit des sans-papiers dans
les secteurs en tension.
- Pourquoi c'est beaucoup plus
restrictif?
L'article 3, c'est un droit
automatique.
Plus longtemps vous fraudez, plus
la fraude est dissimulée.
plus cela crée un droit automatique
que même l'administration ne pourra
pas stopper.
- Les candidats à la
régularisation n'auront plus
besoin d'une démarche active de la
part de l'employeur.
C'est l'un des critères auxquelles
les centristes tenaient.
Les candidats à la régularisation
devront prouver leur insertion
sociale et familiale, le respect à
l'ordre public et adhérer
aux valeurs de la communauté
nationale.
Un tour de vis jugé acceptable par
le gouvernement.
- Cet article 3, comme cet article
4 bis, n'est pas l'essentiel de
cet article de loi.
C'est 1 sur 48.
Il ne méritait pas ni les bravos
ni les hennissements de ceux qui
considéraient que c'était l'alpha
et l'oméga du texte.
- Les sénateurs ont déjà supprimé
l'aide médicale d'Etat,
la fixation de quotas,
et la fin des allocations familiales
pour
les étrangers présents en France
depuis moins de 5 ans.
Le texte a été rejeté en bloc par
la gauche.
- L'immigration serait
incontrôlable?
C'est faux!
Aucune statistique ne le valide.
Ce débat est un débat parallèle.
C'est un monde parallèle par
rapport à la réalité!
- On peut penser, comme monsieur
Jadot, que l'immigration ne pose
aucun problème.
Manifestement, nous ne vivons pas
dans le même monde.
- Le président du groupe LR au
Sénat, Bruno Retailleau, a prévenu
qu'il n'accepterait aucun
compromis avec le camp macroniste.
- Alexandre Poussart: La majorité
de droite sénatoriale a
considérablement durci ce texte
immigration.
Globalement, sur ce sujet de
l'immigration, avec tout ce qui a
été voté, qu'est-ce qui
différencie Les Républicains et le
RN?
- Roger Karoutchi: Pourquoi vous
ne posez pas la question à
l'inverse?
"Qu'est-ce qui différencie le RN
des Républicains?"
Nous travaillons sur des
propositions en matière
d'immigration depuis des années.
J'ai fait voter, moi, la
suppression de l'aide médicale
d'Etat et son remplacement par
l'aide médicale d'urgence.
Nous avons toujours travaillé sur
les problèmes migratoires.
Nous disons tranquillement les
choses.
La pression migratoire s'est
considérablement accrue depuis
quelques années en France.
Le détournement du droit d'asile
est devenu une espèce de
caricature de lui-même.
Il fallait prendre des mesures
fortes.
Ce sont des mesures fortes.
Personne n'est allé regarder ce
que proposait le RN en matière
d'immigration.
Nous avons des propositions sur un
meilleur contrôle à l'entrée, une
capacité de raccompagnement aux
frontières, une non-régularisation
pour ceux qui ont fraudé pour
entrer sur le territoire national,
et nous nous sommes contentés de
marquer ces éléments dans le débat
qui a eu lieu au Sénat.
Ce débat est tout à fait serein.
Il n'y a pas d'excès.
On ne s'est pas lancés dans des
diatribes.
Ce sont des mesures fortes: tous
les Français sont bien conscients
que la société française,
aujourd'hui, elle est fracturée et
n'a plus la capacité de subir des
mouvements migratoires.
Je représente le Sénat au conseil
d'administration à l'Office
français de l'immigration.
Je suis le premier à dire que je
suis pour une intégration réussie.
Pour réussir l'intégration, vous
ne pouvez pas le faire si vous
avez une masse de migrants
tellement énormes que vous n'avez
plus la capacité de les intégrer.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous avez durci
les conditions de régularisation
pour les sans-papiers dans les
métiers en tension: restauration,
nounous...
Vous avez perdu la valeur travail
pour vous focaliser là-dessus?
- Roger Karoutchi: Je rappelle les
choses très simplement.
Aujourd'hui, dans ces métiers en
tension, par rapport aux
travailleurs irréguliers...
- Kathia Gilder: Des métiers qui
souffrent d'un manque de personnel.
- Roger Karoutchi: Ca existe déjà,
la régularisation. Les préfets, au
cas par cas,
peuvent régulariser entre 7000
et 10.000 personnes par an, sur le
fondement d'une circulaire.
Le gouvernement nous dit que ça ne
va pas et qu'il va faire un
article 3 dans la loi.
Tout le monde pourra être
régularisé.
C'est combien, tout le monde ? On
n'en sait rien.
S'il sont illégalement sur le
territoire,
ils ne sont pas
forcément déclarés.
Ca peut être 20.000.
Ca peut être 50.000...
On n'en sait rien.
Nous disons que ce n'est pas
possible. Qu'on dise, ce que nous
avons fait avec l'article 4 bis :
"Ca reste à la main des préfets,
il n'y a pas d'automaticité, pas
de droit opposable", c'est du cas
par cas, mais
nous reconnaissons, par rapport à
des patrons de voyous qui
emploient au noir ses
travailleurs, qu'il n'y a pas de
raison qu'eux seuls demandent la
régularisation au cas par cas.
Il faut que les travailleurs
sans-papiers puissent le demander
eux-mêmes, mais ça reste à la main
des préfets.
Ca veut dire que le préfet va
dire: "Monsieur ou madame,
vous êtes là depuis un
certain temps,
vous travaillez,
vous respectez les valeurs de la
République.
Vous n'avez aucun problème par
rapport à l'ordre public en
France.
On peut régulariser", au cas par
cas.
Nous ne voulons pas d'une
régularisation massive, qui serait
un appel d'air.
Les réseaux de passeurs regardent ce
qui se passe.
Si on régularise, tout le monde,
les passeurs vont en envoyer
de plus en plus.
- Alexandre Poussart: Après cette
modification du Sénat, le
président de la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale a
affirmé que la majorité
présidentielle des députés
rétablirait cet article 3 sur la
régularisation automatique des
travailleurs sans-papiers dans ces
métiers en tension.
Est-ce qu'un compromis est
possible entre la majorité
présidentielle et LR?
- Roger
Karoutchi: J'attends de
voir ce que va finir par faire
l'Assemblée nationale.
Nous avons été très clairs: nous
avons travaillé 5 jours et 4 nuits
sur ce texte dans le respect des
uns et des autres, avec le
gouvernement.
Nous avons avancé.
Nous avons un texte complet.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer à
l'Assemblée?
Visiblement, vu le bazar général,
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y ait un
texte à peu près cohérent qui
sorte de l'Assemblée.
Soit il y a un texte, il y aura
une commission mixte paritaire
entre 7 députés et 7 sénateurs...
Nous défendrons nos positions.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous croyez à un
compromis possible?
Un 49.3 sur l'immigration?
- Roger Karoutchi: Au jour
d'aujourd'hui, entre ce que
demandent Les Républicains, le
Rassemblement National, LFI et le
PS à l'Assemblée, je ne vois pas
comment on pourrait sortir un
texte cohérent.
Soit le gouvernement fait du 49.3
et reprend ce qu'il souhaite dans
son texte, et j'espère qu'il
reprendra un certain nombre de
mesures issues du Sénat, soit on
arrive à quelque chose et il n'y
pas de 49.3.
Il y aura une commission mixte
paritaire et ce sera un bras de
fer difficile.
Par définition, nous ne céderons
pas.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous êtes clair,
vous ne céderez pas.
- Roger Karoutchi: Si l'article 3
est rétabli, si on supprime les
mesures fortes en matière de
régularisation, le Sénat ne votera
pas ce texte.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
des obligations de quitter le
territoire français.
D'abord, une question sur l'aide
médicale d'Etat.
Le panier de soins a été restreint
par le Sénat.
Il a transformé cette aide en aide
médicale d'urgence.
Le gouvernement n'est pas
favorable à cette modification.
Il estime que c'est une erreur,
notamment pour des raisons de
santé publique.
C'est un symbole politique, pour
Les Républicains?
- Roger Karoutchi: Ce n'est pas un
symbole politique, et le
gouvernement est dans l'erreur.
Enfin, peut-être pas tout le
gouvernement.
- Kathia Gilder: Pas Gérald
Darmanin?
- Roger Karoutchi: J'ai cru
comprendre dans ses déclarations
préalables que le ministre de
l'Intérieur était plutôt d'accord
avec nous, même si j'ai compris
que madame Borne ne l'était pas du
tout.
La réforme de l'aide médicale
d'Etat, je l'ai fait voter au
Sénat il y a 5 ou 6 ans sans
drame.
L'Assemblée nationale ne l'avait
pas votée.
Nous ne sommes pas totalement
absurdes.
Nous ne nions pas qu'il y a des
problèmes de santé publique.
Dans le panier de soin pour l'aide
médicale d'urgence,
il y a toutes les dépenses liées à
la prévention, tout ce qui
vérification de l'état réel de la
personne pour qu'il n'y ait pas..
On nous dit qu'il va y avoir
des épidémies dans ce pays.
Ce n'est pas vrai du tout.
Toutes ces dépenses-là, on les
maintient.
La vérité, c'est que j'ai quelques
souvenirs de la commission des
finances du Sénat.
Il y a 10 ans, l'aide médicale
d'Etat était à 300 millions
d'euros.
Aujourd'hui, nous sommes à
1,2 milliard.
Nous mettons en place des systèmes
pour réguler la dépense de santé.
On est à 1,2 milliard.
Tout le monde est conscient que
dans les 2 années qui viennent,
nous serons à 1,5 milliard.
Il faut préserver l'essentiel en
matière de santé publique.
- Alexandre Poussart: La majorité
de droite et du centre du Sénat,
sur ce texte, a levé l'essentiel
des protections contre l'expulsion
dont peuvent bénéficier certains
étrangers. On va écouter Bruno
Retailleau.
- Comment voulez-vous
que les
Français comprennent que ce sont
des individus étrangers très
dangereux qui, parfois, ont été
condamnés très sévèrement, y
compris pour des crimes de sang?
Comment voulez-vous qu'ils
comprennent qu'on protège ces
individus et qu'on les laisse
exposés à leur menace, leur
barbarie, des Français honnêtes ?
- Kathia Gilder: Le texte de
Gérald Darmanin prévoit déjà de
lever des protections contre
l'expulsion pour les étrangers
criminels et délinquants.
Pourquoi durcir encore ces
mesures?
Elles sont déjà dures.
- Roger Karoutchi: C'est mon
amendement, si je puis dire, qui a
été adopté.
- Kathia Gilder: Pourquoi durcir
encore?
- Roger Karoutchi: Mon amendement
a été adopté après discussion avec
le gouvernement.
J'intègre dans mon texte une
partie du texte du gouvernement et
le gouvernement a retiré son
propre amendement en la matière.
- Alexandre Poussart: Qu'est-ce
que ça change?
- Roger Karoutchi: De quoi
avons-nous besoins?
Nous avons besoin de dire: "Un
étranger en situation irrégulière,
et j'insiste là-dessus, qui commet
un délit grave, comme le trafic de
drogue, le proxénétisme, sans
oublier les crimes de sang,
pourquoi voulez-vous que nous
respections l'ensemble des règles
qui permettraient à cette personne
en situation irrégulière,
commettant un délit lourd sur le
territoire national, qui pourrait
conduire à 5 ans ou plus de
prison..."
On ne parle pas de quelqu'un qui
a arraché une affichette!
- Kathia Gilder: Donc, cette
personne perdrait certaines de ses
protections?
- Roger Karoutchi: Oui.
On peut m'expliquer que le
délinquant en question est arrivé
avant l'âge de 13 ans et qu'il en
a 20,
parce qu'il en a 20 et est arrivé
avant 13 ans,
il est en situation irrégulière
il commet des délits ou des crimes,
et on ne pourrait pas le toucher?
Vous pensez que les Français
peuvent accepter ça?
Non.
Si vous êtes étranger, en plus, en
situation irrégulière, vous êtes
rentré de manière illégale sur le
territoire national, le moins que
l'on puisse demander, c'est de
respecter les valeurs de la
République.
- Alexandre Poussart: Pour
conclure sur ce sujet de
l'immigration, Emmanuel Macron
s'est dit ouvert à une
modification de la Constitution
pour permettre un élargissement
des champs du référendum,
notamment sur le thème de
l'immigration.
Les sénateurs LR voient d'un bon
oeil cette annonce?
- Roger Karoutchi: On le voit d'un
très bon oeil.
Nous, au mois de décembre, nous
aurons une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle sur ce thème de
l'immigration.
Si le président de la République
ouvre le champ du référendum et
que ça devient possible sur
l'immigration, nous serons
demandeurs d'un référendum pour
lever les verrous constitutionnels
sur l'immigration.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce sera le mot de
la fin.
Merci d'avoir été notre invité.
- Alexandre Poussart: A la semaine
prochaine.